david bonjour alors nouveaux
rassemblements contre la loi bioéthique
aujourd'hui à paris est-ce que la
mobilisation est au rendez vous eh bien
oui à amira pour le moment la
mobilisation est au rendez vous le voyez
dans une ambiance assez fsi avec une
scène qui s'est monté à derrière moi
l'objectif est toujours le même temps le
retrait de cette proposition de loi
bioéthique et éviter que la vie devienne
un commerce le retrait également du
premier article de cette loi bioéthique
est concernant la procréation
médicalement assistée
à l'initiative de ce rassemblement le
collectif manif pour tous vous propose
la députée à sa présidente est divine de
la rochère ainsi qu'un père de famille
venu à manifester son mécontentement ici
devant les ministères de la santé oms
très bref ce que nous demandons c'est le
retrait de ce projet de loi de
bioéthique ça n'est pas le moment
olivier verront le ministre de la santé
qui est le premier à porter ce texte
comme ministre de la santé à d'autres
urgences à traiter d'autres priorités il
est en grande difficulté
les français souffrent et nous demandons
aux sénateurs qu'ils ne soient pas comme
la feuille morte au vent qui veulent au
gré des avis et des opinions
mais qu'ils sachent tout simplement
reconnaître et prendre en compte le fait
que tous les enfants y compris les
enfants nés par pma ont besoin
évidemment et le droit dans la mesure du
possible d'avoir un père et une mère
trouve que la pma santerre et là j'ai
pas c'est pour moi inacceptable
parmi nous quelles femmes seraient
prêtes aujourd'hui enfanté l'enfant
l'enfant d'un autre si ce n'est par
une contribution financière parce que
c'est une personne démunie donc c'est
pour ça que je suis là aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment pour montrer les conséquences
que cette loi aura à travers le monde
cette loi bioéthique elle sera en
deuxième lecture à cette semaine cette
semaine au sénat et ce rassemblement est
encadré par un important dispositif de
sécurité afin d'éviter tout débordement
comme il ya pu y avoir hier à travers la
france notamment à rennes hu a angers où
des affrontements ont eu lieu entre
manifestants et contre-manifestants l
effort de l'ordre ont dû intervenir à
plusieurs reprises tout cas pour le
moment tout se passait très bien devenir
assez festive ici ça paris devant
ministère de la santé